today I want to talk about data science
organizer burnout and part of the reason
I want to talk about this is that I
think this is kind of a common
experience and the more we talk about it
with each other the more we can kind of
get
better so um if you're uh if you feel
like you could you want to share your
burnout Story please uh share it on
slido if you like um this is a pretty
short talk so there's plenty of time to
kind of share stories and
things so who am I so I am um I am an
organ a community organizer obviously so
right now I co-organize Portland R user
group but um I've done other like
organizations such as the Cascadia R
conference which is continuing it's in
its sixth year which is
awesome um and when like I started with
a group like I confounded called uh
Oregon Health and Science University
biodata Club so that's who I am but I
spent a lot of time talking with
Community organizers so this is really
the collective wisdom of
everyone so let's start um and I was
talking with my other uh fellow speakers
uh it seems like everyone has a CO story
this is my co story so 2020
happened and you know it proceeded to
make all of us miserable it made us all
isolated and you know as a result um
just me uh this is me but like you know
I think a lot of organizers had the same
experience of burnout and these are all
kind of symptoms of burnout feeling like
you're alone that what you're doing is
not enough and you know what you're
doing is not helping people
so one thing I will I will recommend if
you're experiencing burnout is start
questioning it so that's what where I
started was basically saying how can I
fight my
burnout and more importantly it felt
like it felt like organizing was a drain
on my energy so I wanted to kind of
rethink things and say how can I get
energy from organizing and the most
important thing and I think this is kind
of part of the moral of this talk is how
can others
help so let's take some time to like
Vision what's
possible so what if your Meetup required
less planning from you what if your
members pitched in and what if you had
support so this is going to I'm going to
call this a sustainable
Meetup so if you are an R person this is
the formula um so you know you take your
Meetup and then you pipe it through
self-care um taking care of yourself
then you found a core group and then you
make your group
welcoming so if you're a python person
don't worry I wrote it in Python syntax
as
well so let's talk about taking care of
yourself so really you know all of these
negative things in your head you need to
stop that because it's you know it's
what prevents you from like connecting
with people and asking for
help so what instead so like reframe
like all of those thoughts you know it's
not just you um you know I just saw
barbie so it is Ku um and you are
helping
people but the thing to remember is that
you come first so I think this is one of
those things is a lot of Meetup
organizers are people Pleasers and they
want to send out like doodle polls and
make everyone happy finding the ideal
time you don't have to do that make
yourself happy because especially if
you're a volunteer you're not getting
paid you need to make it easier on
yourself so the other side of this and I
think this is the key to my talk I'll
say that probably multiple times but um
it's okay to not know everything and to
admit your vulnerability like ask asking
someone to help is like really the core
of like establishing a
community so I am going to read this out
loud because I think it's just so
important so this is Adam Grant um if
you're familiar with him he does a lot
of talking about kind of work and how we
can make work not suck um so he says
admitting that we have something to
learn doesn't just show humility it
improves
relationships when we acknowledge that
we don't know everything others feel
more psychologically safe and become
more effective so expressing our desire
to get better can can help others get
better so really the key I want you to
remember is that you're not alone and
this vulnerability is going to connect
you with other
people so we talked about taking care of
ourselves so let's start talking about
building a core group and this was
advice that just came from multiple
organizers is to start small and we'll
talk more about that in a little bit so
a core group you share interests you
know we all like data and you want some
of us want to discuss it um and part of
what the advice that I got from almost
everyone is don't organize
Alone um it's and part of the reason for
that is you know when each other is
feeling burned out the others can help
support
them so how do you find this Core group
I and um I just went through the rladies
organization guide they had they have a
lot more advice on this this is just my
little bit of advice um so I think it's
really it's a lot of people put out a
call like if anyone wants to help I
think if you want to build a core group
I think you should ask um ask people
directly I think it's one of those
things that forms a strong connection
and you know people are really glad that
you thought of
them so now you've established this Core
group so let's talk about like your
values as a group and so like you know
remember we talked about vulnerability
is important values are also important
so us at Portland our user group you
know our values are we want we want to
learn together and that kind of informs
everything that we do but we also want
to be fun and we want to wel welcome
beginners so that Al also like you know
informs all of our Communications we try
to make it as as encouraging to
beginners as
possible uh this is just a note so I
know a lot of you do internal meetups um
for an
organization so I just want to make a
pitch that you ask your boss to give you
some protected
time um because this is a lot of work
you know you're putting a lot of like
emotional effort and you're connecting
people you know you need to get Buy in
from the higher
ups so um I think I'm just kind of
zooming through this talk but that's
fine um so let's talk about making your
group welcoming and I also want to kind
of end with some examples of activities
that are kind of low risk and high
reward so you know you have your core
group and like almost everyone I said
like you know that Core Group group is
going to grow like either by word of
mouth and like you know slowly people
are going to start um joining your
group so one thing that I I spent a lot
of time kind of talking and researching
with people was you know how do you make
how do you make a group psychologically
safe for everyone you know and this is
core to kind of welcoming
people so the formula I kind of came up
came came up with is you know safety is
values Plus Code of
Conduct so there's been a lot written
about code of conduct and if you go to
my uh the website there'll be a link
later um there's going to be lots of
links to like you know codes of conduct
and how you should think about them so
that really codes of conduct really
address kind of the unacceptable
Behavior but I think the other side is
that you have to encourage values and
because Val values are what kind of
Drive positive behavior so it's not just
a code of conduct it's also you know
making people feel like they're valued
and you know expressing those
values so let's kind of end with uh you
know activities and I think one of the
things that will help alleviate burnout
is making it easy for other people to
contribute and I loved reva's example of
like you know having kind of making our
ladies modular because you know it's I
think all groups have people who want to
help you just have to make you have to
just kind of make the way for
them so one of the easy low-risk kind of
activities you know I think almost every
organizer has done is lightning talks so
lightning talks are
great but you know I want to just kind
of show this is something that we do in
Portland our user group and you know
part of our goal is just to help each
other so we do this thing this is kind
of our default activity and it's called
Aggregate and all of us kind of come in
with like issues um or problems we want
to solve or something we want to share
and you know often times like none of us
like you know we don't know anything
about it but like collectively we can
figure out figure things out and I think
that's one of the that's one of the most
fun things about Portland are is that
kind of um that kind of collective
knowledge and sharing with each
other so this is just an example um so
you know what we do um it's pretty
pretty lowkey way to kind of organize a
a Meetup um we basically may have you
know a short talk or demo but then we
basically you can see this this intro
section we ask basically ask everyone to
sign in with your name and background
and what you want to learn and show
today so this is something that like you
know and then we go down the list we try
to hit as many people as possible and
you know we try to find find
answers uh this is another activity that
I've done um within a biodata club which
is the idea of exploring data together
so I call it a data scavenger hunt so
this is a basically this is a shiny app
I developed called that lets people kind
of develop these kind of uh basically
exploratory data analysis so this is a
visualization by um oh God Nick I'm
forgetting Nick's name sorry Nick um but
uh this is uh this is called basically
shows you like information about the
data gives you an overview of the data
and it and these gray bars and the in
each of these columns basically show
missing data so that's kind of the start
of the conversation and then we start
asking questions of the data like can we
see relationships between different
variables um so something like you know
age and blood pressure so this this app
basically kind of gives you the ability
to kind of quickly kind of iterate
through a data set and find things like
that okay so um like I said this is a
pretty short talk but um just revisiting
the formula so we talked about self-care
we talked talked about having a core
group and how that's so essential and we
talked about making our our um our group
welcoming and hopefully by the end but
you know groups are are organic and they
keep on growing but hopefully what we'll
have in the end is a sustainable
community that supports each other and
we can avoid
burnout and this is one of the coolest
things you know I was talking um with
some organizers
and you know the abil the transition
from you know just kind of stating your
values to the values becoming the norms
for the group and I think this is one of
the most wonderful things about doing
community
organizing so thank you um so these are
all of the all of the people I talked
with you know this is kind of an ongoing
ongoing project for me so um I love to
talk with any other data science
organizers and kind of get your
perspectives um and on the right
basically those are that's a core group
for the r uh Portland R Group just you
know our ladies Global I've learned so
much from them um but also our openai
and the center for scientific
collaboration and Community engagement
so they actually offer courses in this
highly recommend and also this is my
tribute to all of the organizers because
you do important work and I want you to
know
that so um join the conversation so um
there is a community organizers channel
in in the Discord um you know uh if
you'd like to kind of introduce yourself
I'd love to love to talk with you um so
the website here this is a QR code but
it's also at bitly slme
durn um and this is my information for
conect in and thank you very
[Music]
[Applause]
much all right thank you Ted we've got a
couple minutes which is good because
you've got a bunch of questions oh great
so Wonder um first up do you see burnout
as more about a lack of connection or
motivation or a loss of Wellness more
than simply overwork wow um that's a
deep
one um what I would say is that there
are the thing I didn't talk about
burnout are the systemic elements like
culturally like if you're in a group
that like prizes over work you know but
I think I I I would I would hedge my
bets and say it's kind of both includ
and including the systemic part
hopefully that is a good
answer it's a fantastic answer because
it's your answer all right um next up
how do you handle being an organizer or
becoming one if you are a serious
introvert this is a really good
one I think part of it um and this is
something that I've learned over a lot
of time is kind of you
know if you're an introvert you're very
good at inhabiting a role and so kind of
figuring out what that role is for
yourself is one of the ways that you can
be very outgoing uh to me I kind of
think of it like a mask or a costume or
a uniform and that helps me kind of
reach out and interact with people I
think also like you know just realizing
that you know there's all of these
dependencies and people uh people are
you know want to connect with with each
other is having that kind of positive
attitude um but yeah I have a lot to say
about introversion um and it's taken me
kind of a long time to even get to this
point but um yeah so please please reach
out and we can talk more about it all
right shout out to all the introverts in
the room we see you
yeah all right uh last one on our list
so uh serial organizers seem to be
integral into getting things up and
running but that adds strain on just a
few people so do you think that sort of
always how it's going to be or can you
imagine that as something thing that
will change so I guess you know and I
think the best test of an organization
is whether you're able to leave it and
it keeps on
thriving but it takes a lot of effort to
get there and it takes a lot of
dedication for for the core group so I
think um a lot of the
times and I think the r ladies
organization guide has a lot of thoughts
on this is like being able to kind of
split things into
roles and basically uh you know make
sure that no one one person is doing all
of the work so and so yeah basically
take all of reva's advice and make it
modular all right fantastic let's thanks
Ted
[Applause]
again